foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell Join This Hour by Ramsey
personality Jade warshaw and we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five this is the
show where we tell you the truth even if
it hurts your feelings a little bit
because we love you enough to see you
win when it comes to your money in your
life and so if you're ready for that you
need a second opinion you heard
something from your broke brother-in-law
you saw something on Tick Tock Jade and
I are here to to spit some facts ooh yes
drop some bars some knowledge we'll see
about that that's a that's a big promise
Jade are you ready to go yeah I'm ready
let's do it let's kick it off with Sarah
in my hometown of Boston Massachusetts
Sarah welcome to the show
foreign
thank you so much for taking my call
sure how can we help
um well we recently came across the
Ramsey Show and all the personalities
about a month ago from a referral from a
co-worker awesome
and it has already helped tremendously
and keeping me a little bit grounded
um I am in a situation recently
um where myself and my two children I'm
a single mom
um recently and unexpectedly had to move
out of the house that we were renting
um uh for the past seven years
um you know fairly quickly
um so now I am in a situation
um that uh I can't afford the apartment
I can't afford the rent that I'm paying
now
um it's it's quite a bit more
um and I feel really stuck and
overwhelmed and I don't really know how
to move forward
going from here
what are you paying for rent right now
um right now I am paying 3 300 a month
plus utilities and how much are you
bringing in monthly for your income
after taxes um
afterwards my take-home pay after my car
payment insurance come out is 5900 a
month
and that's app you said that's after
insurance and car
after insurance and car payment are
taken out what about before the car
payment what's your car payment
uh 600. oh
I know
what do you do let's talk about that a
little bit let's see if we can alleviate
that
um how much is that car worth
I bought it two years ago
again when I was paying much lower rent
um and I paid I think 36 for it at the
time right now two years later I owe 27.
in my mind there's a couple of ways to
go with this and if you like the
apartment you don't want to uproot your
family and move yet again the answer
lies within that car note
okay and if I were to say that the
apartment is is not great
um for the money
um it was the only option of choice that
we could find at the time
um that accepts that is an actual three
bedroom and accepts pets they're pretty
much non-existent but I look every
single day to find something cheaper
that I would move out of this place and
break the lease immediately if I could
when's the lease up it's up in January
and you okay and we can't make it that
far
uh it would it would
it would be a long time
um so I you know again and I'm then
looking at the situation of you know do
I break the lease and move into
something cheaper
um but then you have the
um
sorry to break in how old are your kids
uh my son is 17 he still has one year
left in high school my daughter is
almost 19. so they need their own rooms
okay from college yes how soon do you
think they would be out of the house
probably not soon they'd live at home
through college they do they do okay and
I'm sure my son will be wanting to start
college after he graduates next year I
still think that the answer because even
if if you're moving around I I your car
note is still a huge issue and it's
still in position
um in your budget right now do you have
any other debt
I have coming up in September
for my daughter there's an 8 700 school
loan that will start needing to be paid
back
um other than that in the car I only
have maybe 800 medical and 500 on a
credit card and that's it
well there's only one way out of this
and it starts with you saying I'm going
to quit borrowing money which I know is
hard because right now you're pinned
against the wall and you're going well
my credit card I got to use to cover the
bills right
um no I don't I actually don't use
credit cards that's great I don't have
any other credit card bill I don't this
was for like a coach purchase and
there's actually no interest accruing on
it at all I have like four years to pay
it off with no interest so let's not let
that hang around though part of that
mentality is what got us here is going
well it's zero interest I could play the
game I'm gonna beat the system it's
gonna be okay and here we are we can't
breathe right right and so it sounds
little to me but it's a big moment where
we say never again am I gonna borrow
money
sure and so part of that is cutting up
the card closing the account paying the
500 bucks let's move on to the 800
medical bill let's get that out of our
life all those little ankle biters is
going to give you some clarity and some
breathing room to go all right I'm gonna
attack the next next biggest at the next
one you know right
um I do I do have money in savings how
much
53 5300 52 000. whoa what hold up hold
up hold up hold up Sarah how can you
bury the lead like that we're out here
feeling sorry for you okay okay so this
is where I'm not good with my finances I
I've literally gone from one end of the
spectrum to barely paying a rent to
paying 300 times more let me give you
I'm gonna give you a plan right here I'm
gonna give you a plan right here you got
in savings we're gonna walk through the
baby steps and that's what this all goes
back to Sarah so you're gonna start
you're going to keep and and just walk
through the steps with me you're gonna
first start out by setting aside a
thousand dollars that's step one then
you're gonna take the extra money that
you have you're gonna pay off this debt
the car the 8 700 that's coming up
whatever debt you have laying around
you're gonna get yourself debt free and
then whatever's left on that you're
gonna use that to build your three to
six months of emergency fund that's how
that works now do you think that if you
freed up got rid of that car payment and
freed up that 600 a month that you could
hang out
in this apartment at least until January
and then you can reevaluate so you're
not breaking a lease do you think that
that would change your life I think it
would
um I'm not sure I I have that constant
not a fear the answer is yes
it's six hundred dollars no or six
hundred dollars yes
you're adding that into your monthly
cash flow of course that's going to
change your world and you have no debt
and no payments
the answer Sarah is it is yes you're
going to sleep so much better at night
and you're gonna have pretty well on
your way you know you're gonna have a
decent savings uh account there you're
probably gonna need to add a little bit
more to it but that's that's the answer
you're debt free tomorrow yeah with a
pile of money left over and now you have
your greatest wealth building tool back
in your corner your income you make six
figures don't you gross salary
um 124 salary yeah and yet we're sitting
here broke
that's a problem you make great money
you work so hard and there's nothing to
show for it because we got payments out
of our eyeballs and we got Sky High rent
so you may want to look into moving
further out could you move further out
outside of the city
I could uh I am outside of the city
um rents are pretty sky high everywhere
and I think being limited to a three
bedroom that accepts test is pretty much
non-existent it's out there I'm gonna
keep searching I'm from that area I know
it stinks to have to move further it
might be a longer commute but if it
gives you breathing room in your budget
and you got no debt you are going to
survive you're going to make it cheering
you on Sarah thanks for the call this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
I'm Ramsey personality George Campbell
joined this hour by Jade warshan we're
taking your calls about life and money
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five all right Jay the team likes to
throw some videos at us I don't know
that I've seen this video have you seen
it I've seen parts of it yes well it
involves a man by the name of John Cena
you heard it can't see me that's all I
know you can't you can't that's what I'm
talking about he he's invaded pop
culture with that epic move and we've
got a video from him that ties to
personal finances and I wanted to play
it for all the nice people out there and
get your take on it you ready yes roll
roll film my daily driver is a Civic
Type R
shut up it's got Tech it's manual
reliable the car is stable enough every
day that's what I can catch you dude
it's a 2020 and it's got a third pedal
my dog and at 145 it's stable like it
goes it's got seats in the back I can
actually pick people up yeah you know if
you have a purse and a Countach you're
screwed and that's why I can't have one
they're a little bit rough around the
edges the clutch is a dog fight and it's
really tough to get those things running
right like they're always in the shop
it's always leaking some sort of fluid
somewhere yeah so if I actually need to
drive a car on a distance that's more
than like 10 miles specific boom you
heard it right there the clutch is a dog
fight
you know we leave we leave different
lives when he's like at 145 it's stable
I'm like what's he oh he's talking about
miles per hour oh no we lead we lead
different lives when he says my daily
drive because because I I don't have I
open up the garage George is one vehicle
in there that's mine and that that's
true that's when you know like I that's
how I Define true wealth yeah and you're
like which car do I want to drive today
man it's a good place to be what I love
about it is a guy like John Cena got
multiple millions of dollars he could
spend on a car and he goes uh I'm gonna
do the Practical the Practical thing he
loves the car it does exactly what he
needs it to do yeah no frills and that's
in let's be honest it's a nice car this
is not your average Civic he's hooked up
souped up for sure probably you know a
50 Grand 60 Grand Civic yeah but I think
most people have this thing in their
mind of like when you reach a certain
Echelon of success whether whatever that
is in your mind definitely movie stars
or Sports athletes you kind of assume
that they're driving the lambo you know
24 7. Royce yeah but I mean I kind of
like when I see somebody who's clearly I
mean we can just we're judging here but
based off of the outward career that
we've seen we're like yeah he's got some
money it's kind of cool that he's just
like yeah I'm gonna drive a Civic and my
guess if you're driving that like he
doesn't have a car loan on the Civic
that just feels insane to me I don't
know George I I bet I think we would be
shocked at how many celebrities do not
pay cash for their purchases wow I would
love to have you seen the stories like
Adele buys 40 billion dollar mansion
with a more I'm like wait she can do
what she wants yeah she makes more money
a second than you'll make in your entire
life so that's a different scenario but
I do like seeing celebrities who are
like look they're just like us they're
reasonable people I love that watch
their money yeah you know what there's
also that side of it that you know what
I'm not mad at John Cena if if he if he
does have a nicer vehicle because he's
worked for it he's got the money if he's
paying cash yes the problem is we look
at Celebrities and go well how do they
handle money well that's how I'm gonna
do it and it's usually to justify our
own stupidity yes and that's a big
problem because we know now the average
car payment on a new car Jade now Rose
to 730 bucks that's insane painful yeah
and there's there's no correlation that
says the more money you have the better
manager you are of the money that that
doesn't exist a lot of people think well
if you have a lot of money you must be
managing it well or you must be making
great choices and it's usually just the
opposite usually it's Mo Money Mo
Problems you know well you're just
temporarily out earning your stupidity
and what catches up with you yes it
catches up it may be retirement when you
realize oh I'm broke but we made six
figures our whole life what happened oh
it catches up just ask any Mike Tyson
Evander Holyfield I don't want to ask
those guys I feel like uh they're not
going to take too kindly
to me you don't want to take the
whooping digging into their finances you
go up to Evander and tell them you've
been you've been mismanaging your money
yes I just saw Mike Tyson fight and the
dude still got it he oh heck yeah no I'm
scared of him still good that's gracious
that was fun it was a man who's owned a
Honda Civic I feel like I'm pretty much
like John Cena I've never had one not a
huge difference other than size and
wealth there we go we can't see you
George I'm invisible mostly because I my
my skin color is translucent I got
called wider than Wonder Bread the other
day well
it was so far beyond hurting my feelings
that actually I was impressed I was like
that's clever if you look for the people
listening I'm looking at George right
now he's got a nice Olive undertone it's
that's the Mediterranean it's a
sun-kissed olive glow
thank you I feel so much better you're
welcome let's get to the calls before we
get taken off the air Megan is in
McAllen Texas Megan welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi thank you so much thank you for
taking my call sure um so my question
um is about how to pay for college
um I you know I have a good 401K I have
about 900 000 in my 401 and I want to
keep contributing to that I follow the
baby steps I've got all the baby steps
done everything paid off except the
mortgage and
um I just don't have anything I think I
have seven thousand dollars saved for my
son's college so should I press pause
I'm on my 401 and cash flow his college
which I could do if I didn't contribute
um you know or maybe just contribute
what my company matches or should I have
him do a student loan
have you considered is he planning on
working while he's in college
I don't know I mean I've considered that
he will work during the summer you know
but of course a summer job for a
teenager only makes him about two
thousand dollars
um you know grades are the priority but
that that could be an option I suppose
what if I told you that students who
choose to work through college tend to
manage their time better they tend to
have higher gpas
what's the discussion been with him it
sounds like you have you just said hey
I'll figure it out
I started out by saying that and then
because I did not pay for my college you
know my parents paid for my college so I
wanted to give that to my kids as well
and he did say to me he's like Mom I
know I'm gonna have to help you know I
can get a student loan
um you know part of me doesn't want him
to work the first semester
um I feel like you know grades are going
to be the most important deal but maybe
I'm you know I also don't want to have
my head and stand you know what I'm
saying well what I want you guys to do I
want you to continue to discuss this but
I want you to just to discuss it as
though debt is not an option because as
long as it's there sitting at the table
with you guys then the more likely it is
that you'll go with that route because
it tends to be the easiest route in the
moment is to just go well you know
working is hard making these choices is
hard let's just go with the student loan
debt so I want you to I want you guys to
both say debt is not an option and when
you say that you're going to get very
creative and you're going to open up
your mind to a lot more possible
abilities as to how to pay for this
college so when's the first bill due and
how much is is he already dead set on
this school and he's starting the fall
or what yes yeah yeah he's starting in
the fall he's
done the housing
our housing will be due August 1st and
then tuition will follow that how far is
this school from you
three and a half hours it's in San
Antonio uh okay so he's in the dorms
over there
yes What's it gonna cost you what's that
first payment all included gonna be for
you the first payment I have enough in
the for in in his 529. okay
um so the first semester it's about
twelve thousand dollars per semester
okay room and board which is which is
not like crazy when I hear some of the
crazies sure yeah and you said you had 7
000 safe for college though
yeah well I have
an account and I have enough you know I
can cash flow
for the first semester so I'm wondering
by the next semester can we have another
12 saved
between him working and and you working
Maybe
yeah because you've cash flowed
you're gonna cash flow 5000 of this
right now so you know you can cash flow
five thousand and over the course of the
next semester is there any way to get
another for you to earn another extra
thousand for him to earn six thousand
and there is and here here's my deal
like I know that you're gonna Ramsey is
a three to six month emergency fund I
like a six I like a six months when I go
below six months because I'm a single
mom I start to get nervous I get I get
you know that makes sense but here's the
thing we've got to think about how we're
gonna do this without debt and that
might require some temporary sacrifices
whether it's on you whether it's on your
son but the good news is you guys can
make this happen it's just gonna take
some concentrated effort and for you to
um decide what you're what it's worth
for you yeah I wouldn't pause the 401K
and I also wouldn't take out student
loans I think there's more than those
options go watch borrowed future on our
YouTube channel with him and come up
with a plan because right now it sounds
like the whole plan's on you he needs to
have some skin in the game and he needs
to fast scholarships working whatever it
takes
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour the number to call Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money listen paying off debt is
smart saving and investing is smart we
can all agree on that but there is one
key to winning with money that people
Overlook all the time and that is
protecting your finances from
emergencies and that is where insurance
comes into play and there are a lot of
types out there but there's only 10
kinds you might need based on what your
life looks like today and our team has
built an incredible tool called the
coverage checkup it's completely free
and it will show you which types you
need to add drop or adjust we'll even
rank your coverage list by importance
we'll email it to you and we'll connect
you with some Ramsay trusted insurance
providers so you can get your plan in
place fast seriously this could be the
most important five minutes you spend
today or this weekend
Donald H wrote in and said for anyone
who has not completed this checkup do it
now you never know when something will
happen and you never want to leave your
family in a bad situation go to
ramseysolutions.com checkup and take the
coverage checkup today that's
ramseysolutions.com
checkup all right let's go to the phones
we're headed to Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
Bill joins us there Bill welcome to the
show
hey thanks for taking my call I really
appreciate you guys in the show you've
made all the difference in the world to
me and my family that means so much
thank you
you're welcome my my question is
um I'm dying to be debt free um I just
have my mortgage left that's all I have
left um intentional
and just been killing it with paying
down I bought a home in 2019 I had
390 000 on the loan and now I'm down to
a hundred and three thousand way to go
my question is is I think I might be
going too fast I've been putting like an
average of 6 000 on my mortgage when I
only owe like 2 800 with the loan okay
so you're doubling up
I'm doubling the payments and with
inflation and then now my my kid has
some special education that's required
it's been tough to stick with that but I
have some cash reserves in the amount of
168. whoa
what is security if that is well I've
been intentional with that too this is
my emergency slash kids college fund
that I put 2 000 a month away in that
fund and it's all in mutual funds and
only 30 of that's cash the rest okay
this is the savings this is an
investment in a taxable brokerage
account outside of retirement
correct okay absolutely wow and so I'm
I'm wondering if I I could pay off this
mortgage and then just throw as much as
I can back into it and and rebuild this
up and accomplish that goal right now or
I could wait till the new year and
possibly knock the balance down another
40 and then take some of this I just I
really want to be debt free I'm 58 years
old I've never been that free
um how old is your son
I have two kids uh 10 and 12. 10 and 12.
oh okay so you've got so much time
you've got plenty of time
you get rid of a six thousand dollar
payment you were making you'll free up
most of that except for property taxes
and homeowners insurance that you'll
still pay right right that's let's call
that fifty five hundred a month that you
free up and we can now use that to save
for college for the next eight ears six
to eight years so you can easily still
cash flow college and you're still going
to have a bunch of money left over
absolutely even after paying off the
house now you will have a tax burden
with the capital gains in that taxable
brokerage account that's true
so as long as you account for that in
your math I there's no wrong way to do
this if you want to just keep paying
down the mortgage
um I would do it but I think the freedom
that you're going to feel
of not having a mortgage payment next
week next paycheck will be so
life-changing that you will never look
back with regret at what could have been
and what about the college you're going
to have your greatest wealth building
tool at your disposal to save for
college I agree and it follows the baby
steps because even if he does that he'd
still have enough three to six months
set aside and he'd still have a decent
Nest Egg there you know as a yeah for
the kids yeah I have I put 15 aside in
both both my wife and I work we both are
putting 15
into the retirement um what's your
NASDAQ today and I will tell you thanks
to your show
um 13 years ago my net worth was
negative 280 000 that was my net today
it's 1.4 because Wow Come on Bill you
are an inspiration bill I love it and
you're about to be
have no home payment
because you're going to pay this thing
off
that's exciting I'm dying for that day
do it do it
okay well that's that's what I wanted to
hear because I just was concerned that
because it was tied up in the market a
little bit and it's been down
um you know that perhaps I I think your
net gain is still is still great from
investing for that long even though it's
down right now you know I don't sit
there time in the markets I go what
could give me Freedom today like and I
don't think you're gonna look back and
go well my stocks could have been 10
grand higher yeah dude you don't have a
mortgage payment
that would be amazing I love it you know
what to do Bill we're cheering you on
man I feel great about this man that I
almost had to take my jacket I was ready
for him to pay off the mortgage right
there and then but there's a lot of you
know Hoops to jump through to get there
yeah all right let's go to Lisa in
Puerto Rico Lisa welcome to the show
um I have a question regarding the
percentage allocation that you recommend
to determine how much a home or car I
can afford
um my pay stub shows a figure as my pay
rate and I understand that that's gross
however when I filed my taxes under you
know earned income it seemed to be
slightly lower than that yet the actual
money that comes into my account uh for
each paycheck throughout the year is
much lower so which fear do I use to
determine how much house or or car I can
afford uh okay so you're talking about
our 25 rule for housing
yeah okay that would be after taxes but
before other deductions
okay so it may take some manual math to
go okay we're not including my
retirement savings or my health care
deductions just Uncle Sam takes their
cut Medicare Social Security federal
taxes what is that number beyond that
that becomes your number you use for the
parameters so your take-home pay
right right because I consider take on
pay what I get in my you know when I add
up all the money that came into my
account throughout the year and then you
know that makes a difference whether my
decision was stupid or really stupid
there is no parameter because you're
paying cash the parameter with the cars
is that they shouldn't add up to more
than 50 percent of you of your annual
income
oh okay but as far as payment we don't
do car payments and so we're saving up
and paying cash
got it all right thank you so much
absolutely great question that was good
that one's uh you know we get that
sometimes and it's a smart question
because people are going okay take home
pay there's a lot of different
definitions of that yeah because you can
get your check and for some of us it's
like okay my insurance automatically
comes out of my check maybe an HSA
deduction comes out of my check and
you're thinking do I do I do I use that
number to calculate it but it's really
after your taxes I love how you said
that after taxes but not after
deductions and that helps with the
mortgage side but you're right take home
pay what you see in your bank account is
what you get if you can learn to live on
that and achieve all your goals hey
while investing and paying health care
man that changes everything very good no
lifestyle creep happening there no and
that's big but I love that Lisa's that's
right actually budgeting most people
they're not even paying attention yeah
these are great questions that she's
asking
um yeah do you remember doing that first
budget and it was like oh my gosh yeah I
really remember the first budget it was
a on a pad of paper let's just get it
Financial Peace University with the old
school in the workplace oh yeah the the
um quick budget quick starter budget or
whatever yeah yeah it was on paper and I
remember being very confused we had
irregular income and it took it took a
couple of months to get it down pat and
to get it to where it actually was
working so if you're out there budgeting
for the first time know that it takes
some time to get it right but kudos to
you for starting yeah if you can do that
for 90 days you get the thing dialed in
and instead of feeling like you're
restricted it gives you freedom and you
start to go what does my budget say
that's the boss that's it boss said no
we can't afford it right now let's hope
for next month bars that's how it goes
and we've got a great free app called
every dollar that you can download today
to help you get started making a plan
for that money more of your calls coming
up triple eight eight two five five two
two five this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George camel
Join This Hour by Ramsey personality
Jade warshaw uh Jade had launched a
brand new YouTube channel two weeks ago
the George camel YouTube channel and
it's been so fun to watch to see the
feedback from people they're saying
we've taken Ramsay to the modern era so
I don't know what that says about Dave
but I'll take it and we've been having a
good time over there so I want to
encourage folks that are watching on
YouTube this is an easy you know access
point to go jump over and watch some of
those videos the team it's hard to take
credit because our team is so talented
huh when you think about all the writers
the designers the editors it's hard for
me to go like that was all me guys it's
just my punchable face on there that's
saying the things uh we have a great
time so go check that out over the
weekend and binge watch all the videos
that are out there they're very very
good and George for the record I don't
think you have a punchable face well
that's very kind of you Jade you should
go to the Internet uh because they have
a different opinion but hey if you're a
new listener and you're wondering what
does all this lingo they're talking
about baby step 3B and gazelle intensity
our team has built a really cool tool at
ramseysolutions.com if you just hit the
get started button we will help you
figure out the next best step for your
financial Journey based on where you're
at today so just go to
ramseysolutions.com click on get started
and that will help you understand some
of this lingo and give you a path
forward the number to call is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you want to join the show it's a show
about you and for you and we're just
here to keep keep the ship afloat we're
the ship captains that's right Robert
joins us up next in San Diego Robert
welcome to the show
hello can you hear me we can loud and
clear what's going on okay all right so
basically I was calling because I uh I'm
kind of going around in circles with my
debt and you know it's all it's all my
fault but I don't quite know how to fix
it so in a nutshell and about forty
thousand dollars in the hole and you
know I've borrowed money to try to cover
some other money that I've borrowed and
and some of it's from gambling right and
trying to impulsively get money that way
to cover money that I've borrowed and I
you know but I'm not an addictive like I
don't I do it like once every three
months with that impulse trying to fix
debt right because I have no other way
to get money other than my job and so
I'm just going around in a circle
essentially
and it's just bad you know I know like I
have to stop the the one gambling
obviously that's stupid but
there's just no other way to make any
money are you married
yeah have you talked to your spouse
about this for accountability yeah yeah
yeah yeah no she knows she's done it
wouldn't he we're just in a bad spot but
yes okay what kind of debt is a 40 000.
well so 30 000 in a school loan forever
ago that I've got to start paying right
and then uh I've got about 4
000 and just loans that's personal
temporary yeah but they're the interest
rates that are 100 you're talking like
payday loans yes
horrible okay number One never step foot
in one of those places again no
obviously but I just it's it's you're
right it's just trying to cover
it's like I had to keep borrowing to fix
stuff that I've messed up no you and and
that's what we want to change today you
don't have to keep borrowing and you're
okay we gotta when when you're in this
cycle like this you've got to draw a
line in the sand no more you cannot
borrow your way out of debt it's
impossible you can't solve a problem
while simultaneously creating it that's
thing one you have got to sit down with
your wife no more borrowing money two no
more gambling gambling is entertainment
for you I'm not I'm not gonna lie to you
if you're doing this every three months
and you're trying to do it as a strategy
I don't know if it's medication for you
stop gambling and if you're having
trouble with that let's get with a
professional on that so those that's
thing one thing two super duper
important I heard you say a couple of
things that uh you know you said there's
no other way for me to make money and I
that's just not true what are you
earning right now currently
115 a year okay just you or is that your
wife as well no she I mean yeah together
we probably make like I don't know 106
this isn't that not all right sorry
gross this is like we probably make yeah
we probably make uh if I make like 180 a
year all right so what I can hear from
this 180 a year with 40 000 in debt you
guys are just spending man
I understood but some of it we are I no
no question there I mean most of this is
actually all of it is my debt that I've
I've accrued does she have debt but no
okay do you guys have any savings it's
prior to say that again do you have any
savings
oh if I did I wouldn't be doing all this
no okay so you have no money in the bank
we're living paycheck to paycheck making
180 000 a year I'm just saying it all
out loud so you can hear it too yeah
because I think we need to feel the pain
more because you're self-aware you're
going hey I know this is stupid I know
this is dumb I'm not I'm not gambling
anymore but you want to get out and that
takes a point where you have to say I'm
looking in the mirror going that guy is
the problem and he's the solution and he
makes way too much to be this broke man
correct so here we gave you the first
two kind of in inward things I'm not
borrowing money I'm gonna stop gambling
practically you've got to get on a
budget today and it's a great time
because we're getting ready to go into
May so we can start creating a budget
for the month of May look you have
enough money the good news is you earn
enough money you don't need to like go
out and find a new career like some
folks do you earn enough money your next
paycheck covers the payday loan it's
gone yeah
yeah but my rents do how much is your
rent
2400. you make 10 grand take home
where's the other seventy six hundred
dollars no I don't I don't make ten take
home you said you made 180 Grand a year
no no that's for 12 Oh you mean between
both of us yeah because at this point I
understand that's I've paid some stuff
off too
I paid a prior loan off so what what's
left you got the payday loan 30 and
student loans where's the other six
that's another private loan so 3 500 a
private loan and then the rest are the
uh the uh payday loans okay what is your
next paycheck going to be
when it's going to be Wednesday know how
much how much
it'll be thirteen hundred dollars and
then how about our boss money
she's going to get a she gets a thousand
dollars every Friday every week great so
we're gonna have 2 300 bucks in the next
week coming in
yes and rent's not quite due right no
it's past due you haven't been paying
rent because they're not on a budget
George look look I've been
exactly and this is a merry-go it's
because there's no organization here you
guys get money and you spend it you get
money you spend it and you exactly so
there's no cash flow you've got to get
on a budget I want Austin to pick up
after this call you're going to get an
every dollar budget and it's going to be
the you're going to need to pay for the
premium version because you need to
start planning how your paychecks are
spent the first the first thing is
getting down all both of your incomes
combined because we're doing this
together you're married and we're gonna
spend every single Dollar on paper
before the month of May even begins then
we're gonna go back through and we're
gonna plan when we actually spend the
money so we know if rent is due on the
first of the month that comes out on the
first of the month but we still have the
right amount of money in order to do
everything else that we need to do does
that make sense you make the budget and
then you plan when you actually spend
the money in the budget and that's my
question yeah it makes perfectly good
sense but because I'm in this cycle and
I'm like three weeks behind or right yep
it's on the rent I'm going to pay the
rent next uh Monday and then the
following week she's going to let me do
two different checks right so then when
the first comes around I'm not going to
have the money yet because I just will
have paid all this money towards that
and then payday loans are due again so
what we'll do what you're going to do
cut into my check what you're going to
do first off when you do the budget
we're going to make minimum payments on
everything okay just minimums and then
with with any and all extra money we're
gonna hit we're gonna make sure we get
the mortgage listed first you said
you're three months behind on the
mortgage no no no no three weeks three
weeks be okay so let's get current on
all the bills we're behind on what else
other than the rent are you behind on
uh just uh electricity but I can tell
you that that's not that big a deal and
then uh
I've got a I am in a bankruptcy
currently that I pay that every month
it's chapter 13. so that's going to be
coming up on the 10th but I tell you
that I don't miss that uh and then I'm
just behind on these uh this loan I want
to get I want to pay it off you guys got
kids Robert
I have a child with my other wife Matt
okay I think you both need to go to
Gamblers Anonymous because I think you
don't think it's as serious of a problem
as it is everyone listening is going
these people make two hundred thousand
dollars and they filed for bankruptcy
because they're in this payday lender
cycle it doesn't have to be this way man
hang on the line we're going to send you
every dollar premium use the paycheck
planning tool and that to help you get
on board and we're gonna send you
Financial Peace University both of you
go through this together scorched Earth
We're not eating out no expenses we are
getting a plan to get this money paid
off this is the Ramsay show
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsay
personality George Campbell joined by
the incredible Jade warshaw this hour
and we are taking your calls at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five Courtney kicks us off this
hour in Chicago Courtney welcome to the
Ramsay show how can we help
thank you so much for taking my call I
really appreciate your guys's time
absolutely
um again thanks okay so I have been
divorced for about six years I'm 39
almost 40. and my boyfriend and I have
been talking about getting married
um what makes me nervous is I'm in a
much better situation financially than
he is and I have a lot of questions on
prenups I have two kids I own a business
I have a lot of assets and everything I
just I'm really just gonna like confused
about what's the right thing to do and
still protecting me and my kids but you
know all that all that jazz
understandable so tell us about your
financial situation what are your assets
your net worth and your income
sure um okay yeah so I I say take home
about 150 000 a year I have no debt
um I have two vehicles that I own
um I have about a hundred thousand
dollars in my savings account about four
hundred thousand in various retirement
accounts
um I have two kids and then my boyfriend
is also debt free except for his
mortgage which he only has about a
hundred thousand left on it he makes
about 60 000 a year as a restaurant
manager general manager the only thing
is he has zero retirement and he also
has he doesn't have any children so
retirement is really like my biggest
like hang up I would say
um so I don't really know how to
navigate that
um
can I ask you a question
um if let's let's pretend that things go
well in the more in the marriage as we
expect that they would
and you have you know this retirement
Nest Egg set aside do you view that as
something that you guys share together
or do you view that as this is my
retirement
and he has his retirement
that's that's what I'm like really
wrestling because in a perfect world I
would see it as something shared but I
just know how how really hard I've like
worked for it and like all the
sacrifices that I've made as like a
single mom and
um just like really like smart choices
that I've had to make to do it it does
it makes me really nervous like turn up
okay I could see how that would make you
nervous but I do think that there's
um it's unfair I think to go into it to
a marriage where you're saying I do
we're gonna be one but I worked really
hard for what I have and so I think that
I should be able to have that over here
I think if the tables were turned that
might be a little bit off-putting for
you I I yeah I totally understand that I
think what makes me nervous is he has
something zero retirement he's only he
kind of I mean being in the restaurant
industry he's never been at a place
where they offer an any kind of like
investment like 401k or anything and
he's he's 40 years old too so is he
against contributing to a Roth IRA on
his own when he he I keep I keep
suggesting that and encouraging that but
he just never seems to get there if that
makes any sense
um I even gave him my like financial
planners information and it just he I
don't know he always says I played phone
tag I'm not sure but he says he is
so there's some things you guys agree on
about money like you both agree dead is
bad because neither of you have debt
but yeah we just owned two cars straight
out he is very he's very frugal with his
money he's not like an oversunder he you
know that I do admire and that's great
it's the it's really the retirement
thing that's really like a hang up for
me what would be the long-term plan
let's say you guys get married 22 years
from now you guys decide to retire what
happens then
he just
I feel like his parents never taught him
like anything with that even though
they're retired and his dad had worked
for a union so that's how he you know
that was his retirement thing but they
never really pushed him to like think
about that or to be in a career that you
know he never had any skin in the game
for like his college they paid for all
of his college which he has nothing to
do with the major that he's in so I feel
like he he doesn't like think about that
so My worry is less about this prenup
and it's more that you guys aren't on
the same page financially the prenup is
just kind of a formality after we have
the discussion and go hey there's all
this wealth over here this is not a
trust issue between the people it's we
don't want to invite crazy into our life
it's more about the people in your
circles than it is about you two yeah
and this sounds like I don't want him
mooching off of what I worked hard for
later on if it doesn't work yeah yeah
that's the spirit of it you set some
things off to the side that were kind of
I dare I say passive aggressive you're
like he's not even in his degree field
so I you have I'm just gonna say you've
got a little beef here that you need to
cook it up you all need to cook it up
together and eat it because if you get
married without doing that it doesn't
matter if you have a prenup it's always
going to bother you that there's these
checklists in your brain that he's not
checking the box now I do wonder if we
were to give you Financial Peace
University would he go through that with
you or would he say no I don't need that
um no I think he would yeah no I think
he's he's open I think I think more or
less he's just clueless so he just it's
just a lack of Education
yeah yeah okay well here's the thing if
he's if it's a lack of education but
he's open to learning it and doing the
things and he's like hey there's a class
yes I will go to the class with you
Courtney
um I think that's that's a green flag
but if the if the answer is no I don't
need that you know I never grew up and
he's closed off to it that's a giant red
flag and that's something that you need
to consider and a prenup in my mind is
not the answer it's digging deeper and
asking more questions to find out if
there's more red flags than if there's
more red flags then you can kick him to
the curb but
um do you have a paid for house Courtney
sorry what was that do you have a paid
for a house
probably rent oh okay okay so he's
coming to table with uh with home
ownership
the spices things up it does that's a
that's a green flag so here's my thing
if you do I don't think this is
necessary in this scenario you it's not
like you're coming to the table with
four million dollars and he's broke
right no he's doing fine he's doing
great but we need to get him on the
investing side and he doesn't have that
financial literacy background that you
do you've done so so well and I'm really
proud of you so if you do go forward
with this prenup you both talk about you
say hey this is to protect the
relationship this is not a trust issue
this is to protect us from crazy down
the line but be open to revisions maybe
make it protective at first but five
years down the line say we're gonna
revise this and it's going to be all
ours now
so it's not one thing set in stone
forever and again come to the
conversation without it being uh I don't
trust you you're broke and if we're
going to go through with this thing uh
it's gonna be my money but that is what
it is though unless that is the spirit
of it right now yeah and so that's what
worries me I think we got to do some
soul searching before we move forward
with this relationship or with the
prenup
Courtney wishing you the best congrats
on all the success more of your calls
coming up AAA
825-5225 this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
a home is one of the biggest decisions
of your life you need a partner like
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is one of
the highest rated lenders in the country
and their Ramsay trusted because they do
what's right for you Churchill works
with you to build a mortgage the Ramsay
way one that doesn't bust your budget
sets you up for financial success and
helps you get out of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour the number to call is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Zane joins us up next in Fort Worth
Texas Zane welcome to the show
are you with a sane hey there you are
yes sir how's it going how can we help
good yeah well hey so I was calling my
wife and I are wanting to or we're
thinking about doing the baby steps
getting out of debt and all this stuff
um but the problem is I'm a real estate
agent and because of that my income's
not very consistent
and so the thousand dollar uh emergency
fund is seems kind of scary to us I
guess um there's some months where I
just don't make any money and in those
months uh my wife her income would still
leave us about three to four thousand
dollars short of our monthly bills
and so we're trying to figure out what
should we keep in our bank account while
we're paying off debt so that we don't
uh on the months that I don't make money
that we don't go you know negative or
have to go in a day you know to try to
not be late on our bills
is there anything else that you can do
aside from the real estate to kind of
level out
level the playing field a little bit
there so that you're not so that the
pendulum is not swinging so far from one
side to the other
well I typically we just keep a large
Nest Egg
um we just could we keep 10 to 15 000 in
savings because you know there's going
to be and there's always two to three
months out of the Year where I just
don't make money so that's what we've
done in the past and it's worked pretty
well for us but uh
that's true but my what I'm suggesting
is that you eliminate the two to three
months out of the year that you don't
make money
yeah
um I mean I I guess there's I could
maybe pick up a second job that's not
really something we want to do though
we've got little kids and we're both
already busy enough with our careers in
church and different things like that
well there's a level of sacrifice that
needs to be made for a season we're not
saying take on a side job forever nobody
wants to nobody's like man I just got so
much free time it's oh my gosh we got to
get our butts in gear we're in debt
we've been in debt for years what are we
doing and right now you guys have been
kind of comfortable coast and you got 10
to 15 in the bank you're like well we're
not in a crazy rush to get rid of the
debt we're gonna make it so how much
debt do you guys have
oh y'all are gonna laugh at me um
probably a little over a hundred
thousand probably closer to 110. I ain't
laughing I'm scared I'm crying what kind
of dead is this
um about so 50 000 in student loans uh
another 50 in car and then about five in
credit cards and probably we just had a
baby not too long ago so I think like
six thousand more in the medical debt
what's your household income
oh so his wife and I together probably
close to 175 okay
well looking at the numbers there's
there's a glaring thing that we could do
today to clean up some of this debt and
you're not gonna like it
can you guess which one it is
I mean probably the cars I'd imagine
ding ding ding what kind of car is this
um so mine I have a Jeep Wrangler we
only owe about four or five on that we
could that's that's easy
um the other one is an expedition that
we just got last year what's that thing
worth
probably 50. and you owe what 45 on it
dang that's that's the silver That's the
Silver Bullet right here comes in to
sell that thing yeah let us come take
that off your hands Zane
do you see what what George is getting
at dude you just cleared half your debt
what's the payment on that expedition
Express
812 a month if you had an extra 812
dollars a month would you be as nervous
having a thousand bucks in an emergency
fund
um well I'd still would leave us about
2200 short everybody because you got
appointments out of your eyeballs months
out of the year yeah see this is this is
this is what I don't like I'm just going
to be honest with you you called with
the issue George just freed you up a
good chunk of money but that's an excuse
you put an excuse in there he's solving
your problem for you and you can't say
yeah but you've got to go okay that gets
me one step closer what's the next thing
I gotta do okay that gets me Next Step
Closer what's the that's the type of
attitude we need here Zane to get this
done you've got to be looking at this
going all right great check what's next
okay good I'll do that I'll do whatever
it takes to clear this debt that's where
you've got to be right now and I I think
George was right before you guys were
coasting and you were just going along
and and now you're gonna have to really
put the pedal to the metal and you're
gonna have to you're gonna feel this
there's no getting out of a 100K of debt
without feeling it and without it
hurting you go down to a thousand bucks
you're like I'll take four jobs tomorrow
you need that fire the thousand dollars
was never meant to be enough it wasn't
enough back in 1992 when Dave came up
with it right hvacs cost more than that
even back then yeah the point of a
thousand bucks was to get your button
gear cover the ankle biters and put a
fire under your butt so you go oh my
gosh we're not okay because America
thinks they're okay when they have 10
000 in the bank but a hundred thousand
in debt yeah and I'm going oh my gosh
I'm freaking out over the hundred
thousand yeah that that nest egg that
you have sitting there I think you said
you like to keep 15K or whatever that's
kind of lulled you to sleep on this is
that what you have in savings right now
15K
um a little more it's probably closer to
20 right now okay so think about this
Zayn for one second you would clear the
medical debt the credit card debt and
the Jeep just like that today right now
add up all those payments how what does
that add up to five six hundred bucks
that you were paying on those
see
yeah yeah
now we sell the Expedition boom we just
cleared another 800 bucks so now we're
up to what 1300 up from where we were
you get a side job making an extra 700 a
month now we're 2 000 up
now all that's left is student loans
when we start crushing those and that
thing's gone you're making 180 and you
got a 50 000 student loan it's gone in
what eight months probably
with your income
yeah well that's probably doable and
then I'm up in my my marketing game with
referrals with real estate I'm going I'm
about to sell some houses
do you see that saying that's exciting
in a year's time
your life is totally different
now you're not the one who has to go to
my wife and tell her to sell the car but
yeah oh yeah you're right you're right
we don't have to be there for that
you'll be strong though because she's if
you lay it out the way that we just
showed you literally the way that George
just said it you write these sit down
with her tonight and say hey man I've
been thinking uh don't say hey man say
love of my life I've been I've been
thinking about this and and write this
out and lay out that plan and say do you
understand what we'd be able to
accomplish and really make sure that
you're playing up you know you guys's
goals and your dreams for the future
this is an offer that few could refuse
am I right George I mean you lay out the
vision not just tomorrow because
tomorrow sucks tomorrow we get where we
amputate the Tahoe right amputate the
expedition in this case but think about
what three years from now
three years from now most people who
don't follow this stuff are calling us
back going hey we're further in the hole
we thought having 10 000 in the bank was
going to save our butts and the interest
and the payments and we're further in
debt or three years from now
you have no debt in the world you have a
fully funded emergency fund you're
maxing out your retirement accounts and
you drive cars that are paid for um
that's a vision right there
and then you go hey honey if I don't
make money that month we're gonna be
okay
yeah no that's that's the big reason we
don't owe people money and that's the
freedom that that's that's true Freedom
right there right now what y'all are
coasting on that's that's the fake stuff
that 15K that you're sitting on is fake
let's make it real have you guys been
through financial base University Zane
no
uh our church just did it but I was I
was too smart to sign up
I figured out well hey I'm gonna give it
to you for free so that you can start a
class or join a class that's happening
in your area or online and we're going
to help you get your wife on board
because sometimes I know I'm not very
good at convincing my wife of any of
anything yeah but I'll tell you Dave
Ramsey he's quite the convincer and when
you watch those videos usually it takes
a lesson or two and all of a sudden
you're like I get it yeah I get it let's
do this and they get more amped up than
the spouse absolutely and I mean here's
the thing with them it's not even going
to take that long it's just making a
couple of key decisions locking it in
and just kind of grid and bear it is it
grin and Barrett grin and bear it for a
minute and and then you're through I'm
seeing a theme in today's show Jade
people that are making a hundred eighty
thousand dollars a year are broke
because everyone goes well Jade if I
just made more money nope you'd be the
next day yep you'd be the next Brad
calling in going I made great money I
just don't know where it's going man
paycheck to paycheck it's going to let
vendors making them Rich helping them
sponsor the next freaking Stadium
go into your Taquito fix at 7-Eleven
every day don't be a statistic
delayed gratification America look it up
get used to it it'll change your life
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour call us at AAA
825-5225 if you want to talk money if
you need a little hope you need a little
encouragement confidence information to
help you take the right next step with
your money so Jade these calls
have reminded me of a great little
Financial quiz that you whipped up I
guess this
is fun to play with America listening in
because everyone's wondering how do I
stack up how am I doing financially
compared to other people yeah and so
we're going to give you some questions
and if you answer yes to any of these
you might be at risk you might need to
make some changes absolutely all right
so the first question is this do you
live paycheck to paycheck
now it most people know what that means
but for those of us that don't know
paycheck to paycheck is you're spending
all that you get and you have you're
like barely making it to the next month
before you get your next paycheck and
then it's like oh finally I got you know
and it's like there's no room to breathe
there's no margin so paycheck to
paycheck and hopefully the answer is no
but
um
the stats say most of America is 62
percent are living paycheck to paycheck
that's rough so hopefully you're not in
10 people 6 out of ten living with that
stress on their bodies every day and
I've actually seen this stat is variable
because I've seen some that have said up
to 76 percent of Americans yeah
depending on what study this one is from
our latest Ramsey Solutions study that
we did wow yeah fascinating so hopefully
you're not in that group here's the next
question do you need to use a credit
card to cover a 1 000 emergency so if
today you know the car broke down you go
to the shop and they're like yeah it's
going to be a thousand dollars what do
you do do you have that money sitting in
the bank ready to protect you or do you
need to turn to American distress to
help you out yikes so you already do the
majority well the stats say 57 of us
adults are currently unable
to afford a thousand dollar emergency
and I just know this that 36 of
Americans have zero saved so forget it
forget it 800 or a 700 they can't do
anything they have zero
oh my goodness where do you fit in get
in where you fit in all right this one
George do you depend on a credit card to
cover any regular monthly expenses
this one would shock me if the majority
said yes because hopefully you've got
the income to at least cover regular
monthly expenses no George I don't think
people know what they're spending and I
don't think most people understand like
needs and wants kind of thing so it's
like well and this tells us 49 of
Americans depend on credit cards just to
cover essential living expense like
groceries it's crazy because 99 tell me
that they just use credit cards for the
rewards and they pay it off every month
somebody's lying
somebody's in here lying who's lying
come at me bro I know who's lying and
you know you know who I'm talking to
right now okay who would be worried I
know some folks listening right now
would you be worried that you couldn't
cover living expenses for one month if
you lost your job wow
so this is talking about having an
emergency fund yeah you lose all income
how long until you go I can't pay bills
anymore well we know based on the other
question most people don't even have a
thousand dollars saved so you're not a
real Bleak quiz Jade you couldn't have
thrown some fun ones in there I want
people to understand the state of their
finances and this is really serious it
says 68 again way more than the majority
of people are worried that they would
not be able to they're not look they're
worried that they wouldn't be able to
cover it we know they would not be able
to cover it we're telling you the answer
um just for one month they lost their
job that's that's scary that's scary
stuff all right
two more questions guys I don't want to
like dig you into a dark hole all right
are you Unsure how much money you will
need for retirement oh that's an
interesting one do you have a number in
mind have you done the math I don't
think I don't think people know George
this one says most Americans have less
than 50 000 saved for retirement
you don't need to have your cornbread
down in the middle to go I need more
than that
so regardless of knowing the number
people aren't planning for it no they
don't know the number they're not
planning for it wow okay this is the
final one do you think you need the
right job and the right salary to become
a millionaire these days oh that's a fun
one I love that one because most people
have the excuse well Jay I'm just not if
I had a better job if I made more money
then I could become a millionaire can I
can I can I'm just gonna tell you I put
this question on there because I wanted
to debunk the peoples and here's the
thing guys 33 of millionaires never ever
made more than six figures
in their entire world their entire
working life it's it's top professions
engineer accountant and teacher
can you believe that so debunking that
and wow if so let's let's grade
everybody here George okay
whoo one two three four five six there's
six questions on here okay so if you
answered yes to any of the five
questions or six questions you're at
risk and financially vulnerable
so just even to one question I'm
guessing this quiz isn't the thing that
let them know that though it was a
reminder yeah that they're not doing
okay financially yeah if you know you're
not doing well you're feeling it in your
body right you're you're stressed you
got anxiety you can't sleep at night
you're living paycheck to paycheck
you're getting in fights with your
spouse you you know so the question that
becomes what what are you going to do
about it clearly a lot of these
questions point to the problem of debt
that's one part of the equation we got
to get out of debt Take Back Control of
our wealth building tool our income
there's also another part investing for
the future yes so important and you know
at the end of the day you know you guys
hear us talk about Financial Peace
University all the time and I think a
lot of people think oh let's just get
out of debt it's just get out of debt no
if you take Financial Peace University
you're going to learn how to take care
of everything that was on this quiz from
the getting out of debt part to the
budgeting part so you're not paying
living paycheck to paycheck to figuring
out how to get your savings right so
you've got savings for emergencies and
savings for the Long Haul not to mention
we're going to make sure you're Building
Wealth so that on down the line when you
do retire because you can't work forever
right we're going to make sure that
you're set up you've got your retirement
on Lock and hopefully one day you're a
baby steps millionaire that's the end
goal so you can live and give like no
one else it's not just you know Rob and
Peter to pay Paul and getting through
each month it's in paying off to it's
we're getting you somewhere we're really
trying to change your finances and
change your family tree well the biggest
thing I realized when I went through
Financial Peace University it was like
light bulb moment when I stopped paying
for the past I can start building for
the future say that again George when
you stop paying for the past you can
start building for the future and too
many of us live life in a rear view
mirror and we got a crick in our neck
because we're just looking back there
going oh there's Sally May yeah there's
the other lender there's discover
they're all coming there's my buy now
pay later oh there's my Apple pay later
and instead when you look at through the
windshield and go oh my gosh I don't
have to worry about what happened last
month four months ago I can be looking
towards the future what are my savings
goals how am I going to get there when
do I want to retire how long do I want
to have to work for before I get to work
those are different questions to ask
yourself and you can't do that until you
get out of debt have the margin to
invest to hit those savings goals to pay
cash and it is so freeing love it and
Jade if you want to get smarter with
your money along with all of America we
just had a baller smart conference here
at our new Ramsey Event Center and I got
to talk with people outside and we did a
fun YouTube channel segment asking about
their dumbest money mistakes and there
was some hilariously and sad money
mistakes yeah but then I asked where are
you now what's your biggest money win
and they're going oh we're in baby step
six we're almost done paying off we're
baby steps millionaires wow we gotta pay
for a house and these mistakes they
weren't like 20 years ago some of them
were five years ago so it's the term
seven years ago their turnaround was so
encouraging to go oh
I I was done with money I don't have to
stay like that so good and so if you
want to join us we're doing smart
conference weekend again in the windy
city Chicago Illinois September 15th and
16th for all you new folks out there
smart conference is our biggest event we
do at Ramsey whether you've been working
the baby steps for 10 years or two weeks
this is the event for you people tell us
they leave feeling motivated it's what
they needed to get back on the plan or
it's what finally got their spouse on
board and it's all of our personalities
not just money we're gonna have Dave
Ramsey Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw and myself for two
action-packed days join us for that we
also do a smart money happy hour live
recording that is always a blast with my
friend Rachel Cruz and there's a lot of
surprises I can't tell you but it
involves Jade and her amazing singing
voice maybe we'll bring that back out
maybe so join us September 15th 16th in
Chicago Illinois this event will sell
out make plans people travel from all
over to be there and tickets start at
just 79 bucks for a two-day event wow
it's a killer deal go to
ramsesolutions.com
events you don't want to miss it because
I saw Jade's talk and she brought the
house down and if she does anything
remotely close to that I gotta work on
mine for next year
you're too kind she brought the fire I
bring I don't know the the sparkling
water you brought the atomic bomb George
come on now I appreciate that more of
the Ramsay show coming up
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show I'm George camel
joined by Jade warshaw this hour
we've got our question of the day here
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services if you've got rental
properties neighborly's local Real
Property Management offices can help you
manage them and help optimize your Roi
that's return on investment and give you
some peace of mind you can go to
neighborly.com to schedule a
consultation with Real Property
Management Pros near you all right
today's question of the day comes from
Jim and Nevada he says I'm on baby step
six right now and we're planning to
upgrade from a condo to a townhouse I
know what baby step 6 says but I'm
worried that the condo is appreciate is
not appreciating much would you
recommend to invest our extra funds into
an investment or savings instead of
paying more on the mortgage to cover
more ground for our next purchase so for
those of you listening baby step six
that's the baby step where we're paying
off the home mortgage and so it sounds
like they would rather or they're not
sure they're like hey the house is not
appreciating very fast we don't want to
put extra payments on it we'd rather
invest it or save it to the side I don't
know about that if it were me I would
work the baby steps and continue to put
the money onto the house the extra money
because here's the thing when you sell
the house you're going to get that money
back in equity it's literally I like
doing that for a couple of reasons
um and you use this term which I like it
is a forced savings account you're
putting that money on the mortgage and
at that point you're locked in as
opposed to if you said okay you know
instead of putting this extra payment on
the house we're gonna put it just in a
savings account and before you know it
maybe you've stacked up
a decent amount of money yeah and that's
when I like to say you're opening
yourself up to who I like to call Uncle
booboo
which he's that he's that person he's
that guy on your other shoulder that's
always tapping you to do bad ideas right
he's like oh you got 20 000 saved you
know you have been needing a new car
lately right oh you got 25k you know I
had this investment opportunity that's
that's when it comes knocking and you're
like man and now when it's time to move
you're like man if only we had put that
25 a thousand or 15 000 or even 10 000
extra dollars on the house so if it's me
and I'm pretty sure if it's George too
uh Jim we're gonna put that money we're
gonna make the extra payments on your
current mortgage and when it's time to
sell that money is going to be right
there waiting for you in equity yeah I
don't look at paying down the house as
an investment because the house is going
to appreciate right I look at it as my
plan for long-term peace and my plan to
keep me from doing stupid which the four
savings plan does so here's the thing
there's also an assumption on Jim's part
that if he invests this money it's gonna
make way more than his home appreciation
would have made that's what he's saying
that's what the argument is and I don't
know if you've you know been actually
Googling and looking at the stock market
and the headlines the S P 500 was down
18 yeah last year yeah so if you put ten
thousand dollars in you're down to eight
thousand dollars at the end of that year
yeah and so we're also investing for
short term which is not a good plan we
always tell you invest long term
five-year time horizon or longer is the
way to go
and you said you're planning to upgrade
soon in that condo townhouse so that's
another reason I would not do that and
it's all going to roll into the next
house and I know we've run the numbers
on that the difference between keeping
an investment for five years versus
three or less the the chances of earning
a return on that that's worth it is
substantially less at three years versus
five years like the percentage is Crazy
Dave told me about it one time I saw it
that's cray-cray so yeah
or leave it but I hope you take it my
friend
alrighty then should we get to the
phones Jade I think it's let's go Amanda
is on the line in Franklin Tennessee
right here is she in this building that
would be cool okay welcome to the show
Amanda
hi thanks so much for having me I listen
to you guys pretty much every morning
when I'm getting ready
thank you
how can we help
um I am a middle and high school teacher
like you said here in Franklin Tennessee
and I am teaching an entrepreneur class
this
um semester and the kids are doing
fantastic way better than I thought they
were going to do and
um they are about to have some cash in
their hands and I was just wondering for
these you know ages 12 to 14 year olds
um maybe some suggestions from you guys
about like maybe pre-baby steps or what
they should do with this cash
um we are going to tithe 10 to a
non-profit organization so that's going
to be done but then the rest of it I'm
like boggling my mind of trying to
figure out
um what I should do and I just figured
my smartest thing to do is just we call
you guys and ask you what you would do
well first of all it's financial
literacy month and I gotta say shout out
to you and all the amazing teachers out
there changing the world I mean these
kids they the impact you're having on
them just from this class alone is
immense so thank you for what you do
yeah thank you that is an honor thanks
so how much cash are we talking per
student
sales to just the families here at the
school at the small um Christian private
school and um her just the pre-sales
alone they've got almost 800 so they're
averaging about 55 per student right now
that they'll have cash
um and this is and then they have next
week will be two days of actual selling
in real time to the students and the
family wow what are they selling
there they've all designed made their
own product or service and so they have
marketed it and
um we're just letting God take over I
had no idea yeah I had no idea it was
going to be this this amount of money
and I'm a little floored at this point
so let's say you think it'll be like 100
bucks profit per student is that fair to
say I'm
probably more anywhere between 100 100
to 200 okay per student and it's it's
their money right it's not like the
school has to
like it doesn't have to stay within
their school right okay
well it's all their cash so you said 10
is already getting tithe that's awesome
giving right at the top because I would
kind of flow this into like a baby
budget for them and have them write out
and just have them it'll be real simple
put their income so that's 100 bucks
then have giving saving spending
and giving we have 10 that leaves ninety
percent and then let's set a goal for
saving and by the way in the real world
they'd be paying taxes on that so it'd
be really funny to go hey 20 going to
Uncle Sam
uh you can give it back to them but that
would be a fun just take 20 bucks away
from their 100 just to just show them
some pain that's that's that's the
teacher's tip then I think it'll be cool
to say hey we're gonna save 50 of this
how cool would that be to start for a
savings goal we have down the line maybe
it's a car a lot of them are going to be
driving in the next few years how do we
what if we could start a car fund
and then the rest let's have them enjoy
it and spend some and do that wisely and
go okay we have you know 40 bucks left
30 bucks left what is something that you
really enjoy doing that would be a real
treat maybe that's for some people going
out to the movies and blowing that on
one movie and some popcorn maybe
someone's going to the mall and we're
gonna get a new shirt you know or a new
pair of sneakers and so I think having
that balance helps early on because most
people if they get really good at the
savings muscle early on they have a hard
time using the spending muscle
and I like if you have too much of a
giving muscle that's incredible I
haven't seen that often yeah that's true
what do you think about it would you say
even with the savings could I also
um you know maybe some of them want to
reinvest this in maybe this business or
maybe it's triggered them that oh I
could actually do another business over
this summer
um while I'm not in school so I didn't
know sort of where a reinvestment of
some of these funds I love like that
freed me up of hey it's been some have
some fun money well you worked really
hard on this
um but how would you guys guide these
students between saving and also
reinvesting in themselves in a product
or service or something along those
lines I love that idea
um you know I used to be a small
business owner so when you were talking
about this profit my brain immediately
went to reinvest and so I think that's
just another line item that you add on
that baby budget that George said maybe
you know after the giving because give
off the top and then maybe you're saying
hey you've got 90 left if it were me I'd
probably inve reinvest maybe half of it
and then break the what's remaining into
the saving and the spending category and
that way they're getting to do basically
all the things that you would do with
money other than pay taxes absolutely I
like that plan about it what do you
think
I think that's fantastic yes I think
that's great these kids are crushing it
debt-free entrepreneurs okay at 12 years
old what do you do in America these kids
have a higher net worth than you let's
get our butts in gear incredible I'm
inspired by that me too I love that
she's a great teacher very amazing hey
that puts this hour of the Ramsey Show
in the books my thanks to all the booth
dudes keeping the show afloat my co-host
Jade warshaw and new America we love you
we'll be back with you real soon
foreign
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show but we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsay
personality George Campbell joined by
Jade warshaw this hour and we're taking
your calls at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and if you've listened this long I'm
going to go on a wild assumption and
assume that you enjoy this show and if
you enjoy it I want to remind you it's
free and we would just ask that you do a
few quick things while you're hanging
out with us one is make sure you're
subscribed to the show or whatever
you're listening or hit the follow
button if you're on Spotify or any of
those platforms and leave us a review
this really helps with getting the show
out to more people when they do show up
they're going is this show worth my time
and they see your five star review that
helps us out and lastly share it with a
friend most people that tune into the
show go oh my friend told me about it
that I gotta listen and now I'm hooked
and I'm in a different place financially
and we love to hear that so thank you to
those of you who have done those things
do you look at those reviews
for entertainment purposes
we have a good time with those all right
let's go to Sarah in Princeton New
Jersey Sarah welcome to the Ramsay show
how you doing
thank you for taking my call thank you
for listening absolutely what's going on
well um I think I've had my head in the
sand for a long time and uh you know
just raising my babies and helping them
grow and I just really need to wake up
and I'm a little bit of a panic and but
I'm willing I'm capable I can you know I
can do this I just need some guidance to
you know help me get there a little bit
wow so where are you at right now what's
the state of your finances like what are
you earning do you have debt
uh I personally don't have any uh debt
you know except for you know our
mortgage
um my kids are I got three kids 15 15
and 13. I don't have any college savings
for them
um I got a pretty pathetic amount of
retirement savings
um you know I've got some you know some
money in my savings account and I just
started doing a little bit of the
envelope method so uh thank you for that
um how much do you have in that savings
is it about is it about three to six
months
um and my savings I got about 20 000.
very good I got a 403 b I got about 65
000 and I have a small business I do at
night after I get home from work and
I've got about 20 000 saved you know in
there very good you know that's
incredible very good what's your
household income
um well I personally right now make
about ninety five thousand uh my husband
makes
um more than me so I think last year on
our taxes we were at like uh 220 000
total wow that's amazing good job but
you know thanks so you're feeling
overwhelmed is he feeling overwhelmed
I'm confused if he's in this with you
uh well are you guys on the same page
no no I mean he you know he's great he
does what he thinks is right and um just
trying to do it that's a statement right
so he has a different idea about this
right what does that mean
well my you know I've got like I said my
head was in the sand I've got some big
goals and I think his goals are a little
bit different than mine not not
completely I don't want to make him
sound like a terrible person but um you
know we just don't always agree on on it
but you're saying I'm confused because
I'm looking at this amazing income you
don't have any debt you have money in
the bank why are you feeling overwhelmed
well I mean he's got some debt I don't
have that oh sarah sarah sarah how much
debt does this man have
well um I mean he's got he just got a
new truck so um he put some money down
on it I think he's got about 30 000 left
to pay
um he's got a
um he took out a home equity line of
credit when we refinance what um about
40 000 to put into crypto and that's um
he took out a HELOC to invest in crypto
how much well we
we refined
um and he took out some money how much
did he take out
uh about 40 000. oh God you did a refi
cash out to invest into crypto
okay okay so now I kind of I kind of
didn't know what was going on I I uh so
you just said hey honey I'm gonna do
this now and you went okay I trust you
honey that's what the problem is she's
saying she's been sticking her head in
the sand and just kind of going along
with what he wants to do now she's
taking her head out of sand to and
correct me if I'm wrong Sarah now she's
taking her head out of the stand and
realizing hey some of the things he was
doing were really bad ideas and she
probably should have spoken up sooner
but now here we are did I get that right
yeah I just didn't know any better it's
really not that I didn't speak up I just
didn't know and I just you know he
really made he was confident he is
confident very confident confidently
stupid
that's a type of confidence
I was raising my babies I just I didn't
know so what was making good choices and
and I really think he had a really good
intentions
um and he certainly can pay for all the
debt that he's got he you know he's got
the money
um he's got a 401k he's got a decent
amount maybe a hundred thousand in there
what about non-retirement savings
um no I don't get no neither one of us
have that except for his 401k and my
403b with the little bit that I have
well you said you had 20K saved
uh in the bank yeah right does he have
any just Savings in the bank like the
same way you did
um no I don't think if there is there's
not much okay so let's just back this
truck up I'm gonna paint an ideal
picture for you this is this is where we
want you to get to because there's a lot
of things that are just strewn all over
the place here
um you guys are not on the same page I
think that goes without saying you're
living your life one way he's living his
life another way it sounds like in some
ways you combine your money but in other
ways you live completely separate lives
if you don't know how much money he has
saved you guys live separate lives and
and honestly that's what it is if you
don't know what somebody in your home is
spending money on they can they're
living a separate life from you you need
this it's not okay sit down and say your
financial decisions affect me I'm scared
I feel overwhelmed I don't want to have
any debt I want us to be on the same
page and make all financial decisions
together as a team and right now we're
living like roommates
and I don't know what's causing you to
spend this way when we make 220 000 and
we feel like we're not making traction
and we can't even save for our kids
college this is not an okay picture have
you sat down with them to say those
things
yeah what does he respond with
um
oh well yeah and you know and then
sometimes takes that out on the kids so
I just yeah I think this is hold on is
he is he abusive
no what do you mean he takes it out on
the kids
well you know it gets him upset it gets
riled up and then he gets in a bad mood
are we describing anger issues yeah does
he yell
this no just it's good Sarah we need to
get frustration counseling
I mean I've been in it for him
yep he's in it
all right we're working on her doing a
great job but what you need to do is get
on the same page and be involved in
every little decision there needs to be
accountability there needs to be Vision
there needs to be goals alignment
because you guys have all the pieces you
make a great income you don't have any
debt we can clean up your his debt fast
but it means he has to get his butt in
gear and get on a plan together
I wish you the best Sarah this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw this
hour this is the Ramsey Show
Jade I want to Circle back to a call we
just took from Sarah and we dug into the
numbers they make great money she has no
death they're not on the same page he's
got debt he's got his money and is
making financial decisions that affect
their family it's affecting her
emotionally and it kind of came out
towards the end that they try to talk
about it he doesn't take it well and he
gets angry and we asked about abuse yeah
to which her answer look if somebody
says is he being abusive and you go
no that that he takes it out for kids
yeah and when you mention the kids and
look I I think it's worth noting
um and I wish Dr John was here
um abuse doesn't have to be he hauls off
and hits me right when you're in a
situation and you feel like you're up
against a brick wall and you feel like
this person is controlling you
manipulating you lording over you
gaslighting you that is an unhealthy
situation period not just financially
period and at that point there was no
amount of financial advice we would be
able you know she called saying my
retirement's behind then we got to say
for the kids college that was the least
of her problems at this point that that
was not the root issue the root issue
was she is in a very unhealthy
relationship and she's not alone there's
plenty of listeners out here who I'm
sure when she called they felt that and
they're like oh I know exactly I felt
that not because of Sam warshaw but I've
seen that before and I know what that
looks like and so when she was talking
about that I was like oh I've seen this
and so I just wanna
make it clear that when you're in a
situation like that it's unhealthy and
you have the right to remove yourself
from those situations you have the right
to separate yourself from those
situations because ultimately when she
mentioned the kids that's not safe it's
not it's not a good it's not a good
environment to be in and I'm glad
they're going to counseling I hope they
are going to counseling and if you're in
that situation yes start going to
counseling start getting involved with a
local church see if there's folks there
get in a community where people have
healthy relationships and you can be
surrounded by that and hopefully it'll
start to rub off a little bit more yeah
you've got to have a third party
intervene there and you need to remove
yourself from that situation for your
safety for the kids safety and again
abuse can look like controlling
manipulative bullying gaslighting making
you think like you're the crazy one and
the key indicator to me that some of
that's happening is when you rush to
justify yes well no no they're a good
per they're a good dad though no he's a
good job he provides for our family yeah
it's usually those kind of justification
that tell me there's something way
deeper there's some trauma happening
there and let's not remember let's not
forget the first part of the call I mean
she was very stressed when you're they
make too much money to be that stressed
so there's a lot a lot going on in and
Sarah you're not alone and we're not
here judging you we want to help you and
we want you to know that you know we
want the best for you and we want the
you know you're you're entitled to a
healthy financial situation and a
healthy relationship absolutely
all right Jade about a thousand people
have sent me this on social media and
we've got to cover it on today's show
because it's big news and not in a good
way let me read you the first line from
this Fox News article a Biden
Administration rule is set to take
effect that will force good credit home
buyers to pay more for their mortgages
to subsidize loans to higher risk
Borrowers
this is wild yeah it says so let's break
this down there's a lot of that was a
lot of words yeah go ahead here's what's
happening people that have been quote
unquote responsible you know we don't
love credit scores here but people who
have good credit scores who are putting
15 to 20 down doing the right thing are
now being dinged and having to pay more
for their mortgages in order to help
those who have bad credit scores and
nothing down no
that's the summary no and this is not
spin like we can go political all day
because it is political but from a
financial perspective this is insane
purely yes my no is purely Financial by
the way
so here's the details experts believe
that borrowers with a credit score of
about 680 would pay around 40 bucks more
per month on a 400 000 mortgage under
rules from the federal Housing Finance
Agency which goes into effect May 1st
and by the way if you're thinking I'm
going to sneak under that no it's too
late you would have had to close two
days ago to not get hit by this it's
already happening it's just now official
official forty dollars more per month so
if you have like when we don't preach
30-year mortgages that's 15 grand 15
grand on top of your normal interest
that you're paying over the course of
your amortization schedule unbelievable
so the federal Housing Finance Agency
they oversee the federally backed home
mortgage companies like Fannie Mae
Freddie Mac you've heard about them and
they're they're trying to give consumers
more affordable housing options which
let me remind you uh the housing
Market's been struggling in the wait of
wake of all these multiple interest rate
increases by the fed and under new rules
consumer with these lower credit ratings
with less money for a down payment would
qualify AI for better mortgage terms
than they otherwise would have
I don't like this George so we're
awarding bad financial behavior to help
broke people become broker
and then hurting the people who have
gone I've done everything the right way
from the system right I've got the good
credit score I saved up my down payment
no you pay more now to help cover the
other guy this is this isn't what I'm
saying is not political but there you go
it's you're in this at this point we're
robbing from just normal middle class
folks who did the right thing it's not
even like robbing from the rich we're
just saying hey you've got what we need
can we we're just gonna take a little of
that when you're going to pay for this
so that more people can that that's not
right when the people who have done
everything right they're like hey I
saved my 20 you know I'm I y'all know we
don't care nothing about a credit score
but if you're like I did everything
right I got my credit score up and now
here you are and you're having to to fit
the bill for this it's not right yes and
if you've seen the headlines they're
throwing percentages out there these are
not interest rate hikes let me make that
very clear this is something called llpa
loan level pricing adjustment and that's
part of the picture that then trickles
down to a affect the interest rate yeah
so that's what we're talking about here
and I'll give you some numbers so a
buyer with a 620 FICO score for example
or under 640 with a down payment of
three to five percent which is basically
nothing
they're going to see a 1.75 decrease
from the old rate of 3.5 for that
bracket right but if you've got a score
of 720 to 759 and you've got 15 to 20
percent down you get hit the hardest
with a 0.75 increase from the old fee of
0.25 so
if you look at the chart it's a
beautiful kind of heat map that's out
there and that's what it shows the
numbers are very clear that those who
are awarded the most are those with
credit scores under 639 yeah who have
three to five percent down those who get
hit the hardest are those who have that
720 to 760 who have 15 to 20 and here's
the interesting thing if you've got way
more than that down
you have no effect
um and what's even more interesting
because I know the Ramsay fans out there
they're going oh my gosh I want to get
it home you don't have to worry because
guess what This only affects loans
greater than 15 years and if you've been
listening to the show for 15 seconds you
know that we only recommend 15-year
fixed-rate conventional loans that's it
so you can sleep at night if you're a
Ramsay fan I love that you can just sit
back be a spectator but can I just say I
hate this because I'm sure the intent
behind this is to level the playing
field you know to reduce that gap of
folks who feel like they're at a
disadvantage to purchase a home or have
the opportunity to purchase a home but
I'm like everything every playing field
doesn't have to get leveled George
sometimes you just gotta work for what
you have this is the participation
trophy it is and I get it I'm not here
to go hey if you're if you're broke and
you have a bad credit score I never want
you to be a homeowner no that's not it I
want you to be a homeowner this isn't
the way to do it is to squeeze the
middle class because truthfully the
upper class they're not dealing with
this even if they do have mortgages
their financial situations their credit
scores whatever it is uh their their
amount they have to put down they're not
affected by it it's the middle class
it's those people who I'm trying to do
everything by the book I got my 15 20
and now you're paying 15 grand more over
the course of that 30-year loan I love
this part at the end it says why was
this done the answer is simple it was to
try to narrow the Gap and access to
credit especially for minority home
buyers who often have lower down
payments and lower credit scores so
let's just do what I'm gonna make
somebody mad do what it takes to get a
to pay off your debt to increase your
income save your money so that you can
get a higher down payment there's work
to be done and stop acting like you
can't do that work and that you need to
wait over here for somebody to do to do
the work oh you got Jay preaching here's
the craziest part Jade this llpa
adjustment it helps make the government
more money uh of course it does
new they're going we're not going to
increase your taxes we're going to make
our money another way by squeezing the
middle class a little more I would like
to squeeze them
listen I can't say it any better than
Jay just did this is insane and this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey teachers you want to know how
important your job is just ask anyone
who their favorite teacher was or which
teacher had the biggest impact on them
and without a doubt they'll instantly
have an answer
y'all pour your hearts out and you pour
your souls into your work and you have
an even bigger impact than you'll ever
know you are truly a hero to us and you
deserve to be recognized so we are
celebrating you this month with the
Ramsey teacher appreciation giveaway
sponsored by the Army National Guard one
teacher out there will win a five
thousand dollar vacation to wherever
they want to go that's right and two
more teachers will win a three thousand
dollar vacation of their choosing the
giveaway ends April 30th so don't wait
get your name in the running today go to
ramsesolutions.com teacher to enter and
go tell all the teachers in your life in
your sphere to go enter we'd love to see
them win a five thousand dollar vacation
run tell that I love it all right I'm
George camel she's Jade warshaw this is
the Ramsay show free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Peter is in Tacoma Washington Peter
welcome to the show
hello thanks for taking our call sure
what's going on
well we are debt free
we have been for several years
um we have we live off Social Security
in a small uh pension
and um we've accumulated about 29 000 in
the savings account
and I'm wondering if what I should do
with it to
uh invest
maybe three quarters of it maybe 15 to
20 000 in in what I don't know I was
actually thinking about Silver and Gold
but
um I'd like your advice
and now this twenty nine thousand
dollars is this your emergency fund is
this all the cash you have liquid
yes okay well I wouldn't go investing
the emergency fund because if you have
an emergency you have to pull that money
out and have it available to you without
losing it
right so what is a six-month emergency
fund look like for you guys how much
money would that be to cover six months
of living expenses well our monthly
expenses are about twenty three hundred
dollars a month
okay so let's call it twenty thousand
dollars income a good emergency income
is just under four thousand a month and
you comfortably live off of that
yes okay good so let what if we call
your emergency fund twenty thousand
dollars does that sound fair
okay that leaves you with nine thousand
dollars to do something with
right and you want it
we are able to add uh 500 to a thousand
dollars a month most months to that
savings wow that's great very good how
old are you two
I'm 77 my wife is 67. okay
so there's a few things you can do and
I'll start with saying I would not
invest in Precious Metals
okay it most people run to Precious
Metals when there's fear in the economy
and it's really just a fear-based
investment they're saying hey if it all
goes down my gold is what's going to
help me ride this out and the truth is
there's no data that shows that the only
data we have is that when there's fear
in the economy the price of gold goes up
but that doesn't mean that it's really
worth anything if there was like an
apocalyptic situation no one's going to
go around trading gold we're all going
who's got food Fuel and water right
exactly yeah
and so I'd rather put in something that
number one is not fear-based and based
off of you know people yelling at you on
the TV to buy gold right that's where
you hear this stuff
okay and number two the S P 500 which
tracks the overall stock market has a
much higher return than gold
okay and so if you look at the price of
gold you know back in 1989 let's say you
put a thousand bucks in that would have
got you two and a half ounces of gold
it'd be worth about five thousand today
you'd say not bad right
that sounds good well if you put a
thousand dollars into the stock market
into the S P 500 in that same year you
would have about little over three
shares that would be worth almost
fourteen thousand dollars today would
you agree that's better than five
oh yeah and so I'm gonna go with
whatever has the greatest track record
and that's not based on fear it's based
on profitability of companies that we're
all rooting for in mutual funds or index
funds which is just baskets of stocks
okay I know nothing about the stock
market have you ever worked with a
financial advisor
no okay
well you guys at your age and where your
expenses are at this money's not life
changing either way we're talking nine
thousand dollars
yeah and so if you want to keep it in
your emergency fund that's great if you
want to put it in something like a
high-yield savings account that can help
it grow at three or four percent that's
fine too again these are not
life-changing numbers for you
okay is this money that you're helping
to grow and maybe leave as an
inheritance or is this you're just
wondering what to do with this money
sort of
I'm getting to where I don't trust the
government and the big Banks one of
which where my money is
um I think they're sort of run by the
government or overlooked very closely
and I don't know with this last
announcement you just made about
mortgages what's next on savings
accounts not that mine's a big savings
account by any means but what are they
going to do to us I mean well I'm real
skeptical with the government what what
George said is right you know we don't
want to make decisions based on fear and
yes we just did a whole thing about
mortgages but at the end of the day what
we found is that people who are managing
their money they're doing things the
right way they're able to stand back on
the sidelines and watch this as a
spectator because they've got their
ducks in a row they've handled their
money wisely and now they can go wow
that's crazy glad I don't have to
participate in that and that's basically
where you are right now you're you're
into your retirement you're living your
life you've got this money to decide and
you've got choices and you've got
options and if I'm you I'm sleeping just
fine at night because none of those
things are affecting your day-to-day
life right
right you got up you ate breakfast today
you had a great day with your wife it's
not affecting you
and
there's no reason it's amazing what
happens if you just turn off the news
yeah and don't look at the headlines how
your life is just so much better Peter
so much better now if you want to invest
uh you can get with one of our
smartvester pros at ramseysolutions.com
and they can help you you know fully
fund an IRA for the year that's simply a
retirement account that's not connected
to employer and you could Max that out
every year and it could grow in some
good mutual funds over the long over the
Long Haul at you know 9 10 11 even 12
which is a good return that's a great
that's one option the other option
because it's not life-changing money
right now is you could just put it in a
high yield savings account there's a lot
of those online and that can grow at
three or four percent right now which is
good but I wouldn't I'm not at the point
where I distrust Banks I get it we can
have conversations about conspiracy
theories all day long Peter but as far
as your money disappearing overnight we
would have riots in the streets if the
banks just took our money and ran oh
yeah and I as much as I distrust the
government I have faith in the American
economy and the system and I still
believe this is the greatest country on
Earth and I know my money's safe in the
bank account yeah thanks to the FDIC
well that's what I wanted to hear I hope
a young whippersnapper like me could
give you some encouragement there but
you
've done a really great job and
truthfully the best financial move you
could make you've already done living
your life debt free living on less than
you make
well my wife gets all the credit for
that she's our CFO that's a good how
long you guys been married
40 years wow what do you attribute 40
years of marriage to how do you do it
what's the secret
um love God and forgiveness
amen amen what an inspiration I love it
that's a good call right there you know
there's a lot of fear right now Jade
what what he's talking about I know he's
I mean that hits home for a lot of
listeners right now they're they're
hearing the latest news and they're like
ah and it's just like they're
their face and their muscles are getting
Tighter by the second you know just just
listening to all this come out but you
know you like you said you got to turn
the news off and you got to ask yourself
is this truly affecting me right now
today in this moment probably not for
most of us and if it could be and what
could happen and what if all these fears
are what ifs they're based on just
jumbled thoughts of the future and you
sometimes you just have to sit back and
go let me just take care of what's going
on in my house with my money and my
situation and leave all that other stuff
by the wayside that's right get yourself
some friends Dr John deloney says
anxiety it's a fire alarm so let's look
at the underlying symptom of that oh we
don't have an emergency fund that's why
we're freaked out we haven't been doing
a God good job saving for retirement
when we start to focus on those things
that we can control we got money in the
bank and we don't owe people anything
yeah it changes everything absolutely
I'm sleeping at night and turn off the
news that's always good advice this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
ER of the day comes from Galatians 6 9
and let us not grow weary of doing good
for in due season we will reap if we do
not give up
Emeril Lagasse once said life just
doesn't hand you things you have to get
out there and make things happen that's
the exciting part yes he gets it bam
there it is Emerald gets it all right
well hey uh if you think you found your
next home sweet home before you make it
official be sure to steer clear of
common first-time homebuyer mistakes
okay this is a lot we talked about home
buying and mortgages this hour you got
to learn how to navigate home buying
with ease and avoid the pitfalls when it
comes to buying your dream home and our
team has a great resource for you in our
newsletter coming out this Sunday it's
free to sign up all you've got to do is
go to ramseysolutions.com newsletter
subscribe and you will learn how to
avoid making these common home buyer
mistakes
good one love it all right let's go to
Liam in Tampa Florida Liam welcome to
the show
thanks for having me on sure what's
going on
so I'm going to be graduating from
college in December and while I've been
in college I've been working two jobs
and I've just been putting all my money
in a savings account what should I be
doing with it to make it grow way to go
very good okay how much money are we
talking
right now I have about 3 000 in the bank
and by the end of the year probably
another six
so we're talking 9k
let's say by this end of December yeah
what do you want to do with this money
like what's the goal here
so after I graduate I plan to live in my
car and travel around the country for at
least a year wow what's your degree in
entrepreneurship would you be working at
all while on the road or is the gold
have zero income
the goal is to work while I'm on the
road got it so kind of the uh the
nomadic life you're doing some some kind
of remote work uh you say
entrepreneurship are you starting a
business are you going to be working for
a business what's the plan there
um so am I current employer they might
be an opportunity for a part-time remote
role so I might transition into that
until I decide what kind of business I
want to get into okay have you kind of
budgeted out I think this is a great
idea I think this sounds really fun and
you're at the time of your life to do
something like this
um have you kind of budgeted out how
much money you're going to need to live
off of while you do this for a year
so um depending on how Bare Bones I do
it I could live on maybe a thousand
dollars a month okay and you already
have the car that you're going to live
in is this like a van a camper
yeah it's an SUV okay and you're going
to kind of convert it
is that going to cost you money to do
um
I'm kind of deciding on how I want to
outfit it but I'm planning on basically
just putting a bed and a cooler in the
back and just going man no shoes no
shirt no problem well just showering at
the old Planet Fitness
exactly that's the move well I think
with the money that you have now if you
can just like place it in a high yield
savings account and just kind of take
advantage of the fact that there's
decent interest rates right now and it
doesn't make any sense to try to invest
this or anything because you're
graduating in December and you're going
to need access to this money you're
going to be able to need you know pull
from it when you need it so I think the
plan right now is just to continue to
save and really make a plan I think at
the end of the day don't enter into this
without making a plan for for all of it
you said right now hey I think it's
going to cost me about a thousand per
month I wanna I wanna really drill that
down and make sure that that's what it
is look at your food look at the things
that you want to do while you're on your
trip maybe there's some excursions that
you want to do maybe you know so really
price that out because one thing about
travel is it's easy for it to go get
super expensive super so alone if you're
just traveling gas alone is going to
crush that budget I know an SUV too an
outfitted one so really really do some
deep Research into that and if that's
the case maybe you travel for six months
you know but whatever the whatever you
decide on just make sure you have a plan
and make sure you don't go into debt
over it so we're not using any credit
cards only cash but truly your savings
rate your ability to save every month is
a way bigger Factor than how to make
this money grow yeah because even the
numbers we showed if you put 9000 in a
high yield savings account today at four
percent that's 360 a year that's 30
bucks a month that's not life-changing
money yeah so do not invest it though
going well I can make more if I put in
the stock market yeah and your balance
could also be five thousand dollars
instead of nine by the end of the year
depending on which way the stock market
goes so I would be very cautious with
this money just park it you need it soon
you don't have a long time Horizon but
we're cheering you on Liam that's an
exciting Adventure sure it's not for me
personally because I'm I'm very well
groomed and so hygiene is a big issue
for me but I love the I'm like man what
would that be like look when people are
like I'm backpacking across Europe and
I'm staying in hostels I I I I can't
even talk like I'm just thinking about
that oh my not my back I did it in
college I did the backpacking Europe
thing and this was like before iPhones
were like really great and so we had to
we got paper maps it was a whole
situation look there's hotels here in
the states that I won't be staying in
you won't catch me as some of you we're
too bougie now I love it I'm telling you
I just won't go she's not doing it you
can't convince her all right let's take
a quick one here from Caprice in
Lynchburg Virginia how you doing
good thank you for having me absolutely
how can we help today
light workload at work have taken a four
thousand dollar like pay cut so I'm not
getting overtime and I was already
living paycheck to paycheck um so I'm
debating between getting second job or
going back to school but I also am
considering selling my house I've owned
it for about five years I still owe
about a hundred thousand left on it and
I'm just not sure if
staying is worth it I found a one
bedroom apartment for a couple hundred
dollars less than my mortgage which is
very rare
um because normally mortgage around I
mean rent around here is almost double
my mortgage so I'm just wondering if I
should jump on this or not what's your
take-home pay
um I am bringing home right a monthly oh
I
did 2800 a month and what's your
mortgage I believe so every month
um 7 30. can I ask a question you said
you took a 4K pay cut is that per month
that no no that's for the year okay okay
about 400 400 a month um that I'm losing
not getting overtime so before I start
getting overtime I was working a second
job I quit my second job because I would
guarantee this overtime and I've worked
it
um until about the past month work has
slowed down dramatic dramatically and it
doesn't seem to be picking back up and
we're all concerned that it's going to
be a slow year or two what kind of work
is it
I have never gone to school so I've just
done different customer service jobs I'm
currently just at a desk working for a
Conveyor Company doing manuals and stuff
for their equipment is it salary
it is not it is hourly okay I'm
wondering if you can find a salary
customer service job yeah get a raise
but truthfully I'm not selling the house
the house is not the problem yeah okay
you're right on the money with about 25
of your take-home pay and once you get
your income back up it's going to be
even less than that yeah so the house
doesn't solve your problem what what
else is going on in your expenses that's
causing you to feel this way
um well I have my daughters
daycare which is also like a second
mortgage yes it is
yeah her daycare is actually more than
my mortgage
um it doesn't shock me and then yeah and
then so that's usually about half my
income right there between house and
daycare it's a little over and then I
tithe ten percent yeah groceries were
really really tight on groceries so
we've got to get your income
yeah it's the income and I think that
you can't figure out how to okay just
start applying we'll give you Ken's book
paycheck to purpose let's let's start
there and see what other you know if you
really love this field you know maybe
it's just you applying for other jobs in
the same field but if there's you
mentioned going back to school I'm not
sure that that's on the table just yet
we've got to get your income because you
got to be able to pay for school
and right now things are so so tight
let's try to get a job where you're
making a good bit more
um and then we can start talking about
what it's going to look like to pay for
school as you go and hopefully be on the
track to where you really want to be uh
both career-wise and financially
but I think the 2800 is kind of with the
daycare George yeah that daycare is no
joke telling you four years
you can do it we're cheering you on
Caprice single moms man they're they're
crushing the game oh man they are super
they are super human absolutely what
they can do I don't know how they do it
sheesh well good hour Jade thanks for
being my co-host you were forced to but
I hope it was enjoyable for you as well
I loved it and thanks to all the guys in
the booth they're keeping the show float
for you America which is why we're here
it's your show we thank you so much for
listening we'll be back real soon
foreign
[Music]
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsaysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]